good morning everybody welcome to Sunday
morning science John Perry here today
we're going to talk about signaling
theory and I'm really excited about this
I I work I've been working with Stewart
West at Oxford over the past few years
we did one video on evolutionary
transitions major evolutionary
transitions several years back and right
now we're starting to work on a few more
on some genetics animations which will
be coming out fairly soon on the stated
clearly Channel before that I've got
another animation on origin of life that
I'm working on right now
like at the at the moment right now but
yeah so I've been working with Stewart
West for a long time and he has written
a textbook about it covers a lot of
different topics in evolution but one
that's been most impactful on me is
signaling theory and it's it's really a
beautiful piece of evolutionary science
so I'm excited to talk about that before
I get going there I want to just let you
know it's happening the rest of this
month on on Sunday morning science so
let me pull up my slides here
so next week I'm gonna have Jay Forsyth
on and he is an origin of life chemist
and he's he's also a Christian and he's
gonna be talking about monk mostly about
his chemistry but then we're also going
to dive into a little bit of the you
know that the religious aspect of this
you know how are how are you know
there's actually several Christian
researchers at the origin of life
Research Center and it's it's pretty
interesting to see his perspective you
know I've had I've had a couple people
on here as guests that are are very much
against origin of life chemistry because
of their religious thought and he's
obviously very different than they are
so it's gonna be interesting to talk to
him about that and then I've got Bert
Hubert coming on and he is an engineer
and he's going to be talking about the
cell he's actually studied biology
professionally but he started this
career as an engineer and he's gonna be
talking about the cell from an
engineering perspective and it's gonna
be really cool to have a conversation
with him he's got a couple of up talks
online about this that I've really
really enjoyed so yeah I'm excited to
have him on so it's going to be a great
great couple weeks coming up here
sorry I just had to make sure that
everything was streaming properly okay
so signaling theory signaling is
signaling in nature pretty much all the
things that make you say whoa like whoa
that's cool the strange colors of a
flower the colorings of a bird the song
of a bird the bazaar colors on a
butterfly all of these things are
signaling and pretty much everything
that really blows your mind when you go
out in nature the things that make you
stop and look those are signals the
reason that they grab our attention is
because they've actually evolved to get
attention either for usually not from us
but from you know a bird song is for
other birds flowers beautiful colors are
for it to attract insects for
pollination and the butterflies have
their colors to attract mates and to
signal what species they are so that you
know other butterflies know that it's
it's cool to hang out with them and
there's also signaling that that that
butterflies might be doing to predators
signaling that they might be toxic and
so on so there's all all sorts of
signaling happening in nature organisms
are communicating with each other and
oftentimes organisms without brains are
communicating with each other as is the
case of plants that communicate with
insects through their flowers and plants
actually communicate a lot through
molecular signaling that happens in
their roots with fungi and there's all
sorts of communication you do not need a
brain to communicate it turns out and
this is just a really weird and
fascinating aspect of biology we have
layers and layers of communication
systems happening now my talk today is
going to be pretty much a lot of it's
gonna be based on Stuart West's book
which is an introduction to behavioral
ecology and this is the textbook that he
uses in one of his classes at Oxford you
know he wrote with two other co-authors
and a lot of this is also going to be
coming from this paper I'm kind of
mixing and matching fields here and I
told you I have an engineer on to talk
about the cell from an engineering
perspective and there is this beautiful
paper by Claude Shannon
this was back gosh 1948 and it's a
mathematical theory of communication and
this is not really used by biologists
biologists don't normally talk about
communication in this way but I think
that they should because what he's
described here you know he was he worked
for Bell Labs for the phone company and
he was trying to really really
understand what communication is at a
fundamental level and he wrote this
paper and it is absolutely amazing that
the insights that he gave us and it's
directly applicable to biology directly
applicable and I'm gonna be talking
about this in light of signalling theory
so signaling theory is this actual thing
that developed within the field of
evolutionary biology and then this
mathematical theory of communication
came came about independently in in
engineering and it's this has been the
basis of a lot of computer science
pardon my crackly voice this morning so
signaling theory is that that branch of
evolutionary biology that studies how
communication systems evolve or develop
between organisms even organisms without
brains and then the information theory
is this Universal mathematical
description of communication so this
this graph right here is very famous in
Claude Shannon's paper and he talks
about what a communication system is
you've got an information source you
have a transmitter of some kind
transmitter and an encoder so that
transmitter if we think about a flower
for example of course he was thinking
about you know phones and stuff but if
we if we if we think about as in biology
a flower
is encoding information it's its
encoding information about the fact that
it's got pollen that's ready to be you
know spread about the world and it has
nectar that's ready to be fed to
pollinating insects so they can you know
do their job to spread that pollen and
it encodes that information so that
information exists inside the plant and
it encodes that information in colors of
the flower and in fragrances and there's
actually a lot of pretty complicated
signals that that are being transmitted
by a flower very specific some are
species specific they're they're
actually communicating with a specific
species of insect and you know they had
a special fragrances for that attract
specific species and repel others but
that is encoded in these fragrances and
in these colors and transmitted it is a
signal that is transmitted the the the
fragrances can be smelled for from a
quite a distance away and the colors can
be seen from quite a distance away and
it's transmitted through a noisy source
you know just the environment and that
is received by the eyes and the sensory
organisms of an insect which decode that
information into some sort of a meaning
that the insect understands so that the
destination here is the insects brain
and that information decoded in the
insects brain and the insect knows ok
there's food over there I should go
check it out so you know that's that's
that's a communication system through
Claude Shannon's model and we normally
don't he wasn't thinking about biology
when you put this together and normally
engineers don't think about biology when
they when they're they're looking at
this chart but signaling is it's kind of
difficult for humans to really
understand like the concepts I'm going
to be talking about today take a while
to grasp and the reason for that is that
we are swimming in symbols and signaling
this is Morse code and if you look at
this chart you know
code is these these sounds you know deep
dot DD DD dot and you could send them
over a wire and they represent letters
and so we're used to looking at things
like this charge like this but if you
look at this we actually have symbols
that represent other symbols that
represent other symbols so these dots
and dashes here represent a B you know
the letters of the alphabet but those
letters of the alphabet also represent
symbols in they represent sounds of
words and words themselves are symbols
that represent actual thoughts in our
heads so it's a it's a crazy the we we
are just swimming in symbols our species
we think in symbols our brains work by
letting us think in symbols you know
most of us think in words right in words
and images and those words are just
they're just symbols so because of this
it's almost it almost becomes difficult
to talk about sick about symbols that
end up evolving in nature because we
almost it's it's like seeing the air
that we're we're breathing it's it's
difficult for us but you know just keep
that in mind this is difficult but it's
not impossible we just have to each has
to be careful and and and really think
about these things carefully so anything
in nature can be used as a symbol in a
communication system there can be
tactile signals visual signals chemical
signals and audible signals this dog is
sending signals to other dogs he's he's
not just relieving himself he's peeing
as high as he can on this this looks
like a palm tree there so that he can
you know announce his presence to other
dogs in the area and they will come
sniff that and they'll look they're
gonna get information about who's there
so this is actually a communication
system that he's evolved from dog urine
and I find that hilarious here's again
you know we talked about flowers and
that these colors these colors are
signals
they are symbols in a communication
system so these are visual symbols these
these insects are using chemical symbols
to communicate to each other they're
actually rubbing their antennae across
each other and they're they're getting
information Matt you know who are you
are you a member of my group are you not
and they're they're communicating
they're just through chemicals and you
know of course there's tactile symbols
you know these there's all sorts of
gestures that animals have that they
that they you know there's there's
gestures that can be seen and there's
physical connection here we have one
chimp grooming another chimp and that is
both functional as in there getting
roomed right but it's also a symbol of
friendship and closeness that these
animals are sharing with each other so
all sorts of different symbols that can
can pop up in biology and biology is
filled with communication systems layers
and layers of communication systems your
your body tissues signal to each other
with hormones it's it's fascinating how
deep this goes
so signaling happens between members of
the same species this is a butterfly
fish and butterfly fish is really
interesting they they're they have very
species specific colorations oh thank
you I gotta get a super Chad from
Canadian Alison appreciate that
super chats are welcome by the way and
so these butterfly fish they are there
they're actually signaling to each other
that hey I'm a member of your species
and there's several reasons why that's
important that they know that there's a
member of their species around one of
which is that they they tend to have
extremely specific diets and if there's
more than one individual the same
species on one little patch of the coral
reef
likely it's gonna be hard to find food
there so they're actually kind of
warning each other hey I'm already here
don't come here
I might have to chase you off if you do
come here because this is my little
patch of the woods
and they they also of course signal
during mating time like hey I'm a member
of your species let's let's mate so
there's lots of different reasons for
that peacocks are signaling this is this
is signaling between sexes this peacock
is saying look how healthy I am I'm so
healthy that I can maintain this
obnoxiously
bright colored hard to maintain tail not
only can I survive I can maintain this
extravagant just flamboyant tail so you
should probably mate with me I've got
good genes and signaling happens between
predator and prey this is a springbok
antelope and it's doing what's called
starting there's other other words for
it as well but it they do this when
they're running in a herd the herd runs
slower than an individual can run
obviously because you know there's just
a little bit of chaos and that herd so
when they're being chased by a predator
they will jump straight up in the air
like this and that shows the predator
yeah I'm running kind of slow right now
but as soon as you single me out I will
smoke you I am powerful don't mess with
me so they can they can jump vertically
to show the predator how strong they are
and the Predators know what this means
they're like wow I'm not gonna mess with
that guy and they're gonna look for one
that can't really do this very well and
they're gonna try and single out that
one because they're gonna have a better
chance of catching it so basically what
this signal is saying what this this is
a simple saying don't eat me eat that
other guy I'm I'm I'm not good you're
not gonna catch me this is a really
interesting group of you know signals
that are happening here this is a goby
and his shrimp companion so signaling
happens between mutualistic symbiosis
these two organisms live in symbiosis
the shrimp digs a burrow and the goby
lives in that burrow and the goby takes
the shrimp out on little hunting
expeditions or food gathering
expeditions the shrimp has poor eyesight
and it will touch the gobies tail with
its antennae and it can it can kind of
taste the goby it knows that oh you're
my goby
you're you
my buddy with those antennae and it can
feel all sorts of movements and so there
develops between these two individuals
that there will develop a relationship
between them a communication system
between them where they can signal to
each other all sorts of things a signal
danger and all sorts of other things to
each other and it's really fascinating
you should go on get on YouTube and look
look this up it's really cool to watch
these these companions interact with
each other so languages that develop
between organisms they vary in
complexity from one signal one word to
many so this this poison dart frog is
advertising that that it's poisonous
saying don't eat me at it you will die
or you will get sick at least if you try
and eat me and that's just one that's a
one-word communication system it's
that's it and it's a lot of different
predators understand that that word and
they stay away the be here and the
flower the flower has many signals in
its language it that it has with the bee
it it can signal when there is pollen
with different fragrances it will send
out different signals after it's been
pollinated it will send out a smell
saying shops shops closing it will stop
producing a nectar it'll send out a
specific smell and not and many species
that will change color fairly rapidly
after they've been pollinated and they
no longer need pollen
thanks for the super chat there no it
has Magda Magda oh this is a signal of
appreciation to one of the best evo
channels on youtube thanks I appreciate
that so so these languages can really
vary in in complexity and from one word
to many words
now in computers you have an encoding
decoding rules those rules are set up
and advanced so the the encoder and the
decoder have the same rules for encoding
and decoding and those rules are known
by the in
and the decoder so in my computer my
keyboard it sends out zeros and ones
that my computer then decodes into zeros
and ones that turn into letters that
show up on my computer screen and that
that those rules are set up in advance
and so it it's it becomes confusing when
you try and think about how on earth
could this evolve because these things
have to be set up in advance what the
heck is going on here like how could
something this complex how could a
communication system evolve naturally
Gaurav Sharma thank you for the super
chat as well appreciate that so so this
is how we get this is kind of a mystery
right for for evolutionary biologists
you know they've not been thinking about
this typically from communication or
from from information theory perspective
but this has been perplexing biologists
for a long time and it's because of this
that signaling theory was developed and
so so this is the big question that I
want to answer today is how do
communication systems evolve and before
I dig in there I just wanted to look at
this if anyone has any questions here it
looks like I just got one from a key
side Channel
how can signaling types change
microorganisms use chemical and some use
visual signaling but these signals are
simple but how can multi cellular signal
signalling methods change so vastly so
well if we go to if we go to this this
model here of of communication the whole
point of encoding information is to
transmit it in some way so my keyboard
needs to transmit information from my
fingers to my computer and it does that
through zeros and ones technically it
does that through you know voltage
differences there's it sends out series
of charges to the computer that the
computer interprets as zeros and ones
and then
translates that into into letters so the
whole point is to transmit information
and at whatever scale you happen to be
so the flower is is the plant is this
big thing living in the environment
color is a really good way to transmit
information through the air through you
know through across long distances and
color is also something that I actually
can evolve quite easily color is
actually a result of pigments so and
those pigments are just molecules inside
the cell so it actually is really it's
just it's it is chemical signaling you
could say but it's chemical signaling
inside the tissue of a plant that
changes in the plants color and that
acts as a signal that can be transmitted
through long distances to an insect that
can see it from quite quite a ways away
birds and other things they can see
those so this is a it really is it if
you really look at it closely in biology
these signals are all they're really all
chemical when you get down to it they
really are all chemical and it's it's
very similar to the the simple chemical
signals that we see bacteria using to
communicate with each other it's just
that they end up manifesting in
different ways the signals that I'm
using right now the symbols that the
words that I'm using right now are also
really if you really get down to it that
they are chemical the muscles that are
being used to form these words are being
controlled by chemical signals in my
nervous system and chemical electrical
signals in my nervous system and of
course the the chemistry happening in
the muscles in my throat so all of that
really is chemical it's the same sorts
of things that we see microorganisms
using so yeah it's it's weird how these
things have evolved they are quite
spectacular that question I got from
Canadian alison do we know what the
origin of certain signals are like red
being a colour visual for danger poison
must have very ancient evolutionary
basis right because it's so
and dot it's so common yeah I will talk
about that a little bit later in this
presentation actually the the color red
well yeah we'll talk about that it how
these things emerge is interesting and
once something becomes dominant so so it
actually could be anything anything can
be used as a symbol and a communication
system but once one when we're talking
about signaling between predator and
prey when a prey item happens to be
dangerous and it can warn a potential
predator hey I'm actually more dangerous
than you think
once something sticks it could be
anything it could be a smell it could be
a color it could be any color but once
something sticks once it once something
has got started new predators who come
onto the scene will end up evolving to
understand that because it's that that
signal will become stronger and stronger
and stronger and then new Predators who
are exposed to this danger and are
looking for you you know when you eat
when you eat something nasty and you get
sick you pay attention to what it was
that you just ate and you do not want to
eat that again and so if the thing you
just ate had these bright red spots on
it well now you're going to avoid things
with bright red spots on them so that
that's how this that's how this works
release its other things either learn or
evolve because you can you can actually
evolve a a phobia of red spots over
evolutionary time or you can learn it
with a with a brain so you can you can
learn signals or you can evolve to
understand them and again you don't even
need a brain to understand them flowers
can understand so they actually get
signals from insects as well and they
interpret those and they respond to
those without a brain so it's it's not
that red there's nothing about red this
in general that says danger it's that
red has evolved to become a symbol of
danger because of really an accident of
evolutionary history
now that it's so common other organisms
that are toxic if they happen have a
little bit of right pick red pigment in
them evolution will drive them to become
more bright red because so many
predators already understand that bright
red has a danger and you even have some
organisms that are evolving warning
signals when they aren't toxic and
actually I probably shouldn't go into
this because it could be a whole hour of
talking about this and there's there's a
lot to cover it in here today but that
is a very interesting rabbit hole to go
down and I might I might just do a whole
lesson on on that warning colors and
they're they're mimics some other time
there is a good talk by nancy mirror
Ellie about that and I'll try to link
I'll try and find that and link to it in
the video description see have you
investigated semiotic Sat all I am NOT
super familiar with that no so I'm gonna
I'm gonna get back to the slides here
and if you if you write a question to me
at stated space casually I will try and
answer that I've got a couple of breaks
during this presentation where I can
answer questions so okay
so how do communication systems evolve
before we can really understand how they
evolve between different organisms it's
good to ask ask the easier question how
do they develop between thinking animals
so this is my dogs Zoey and you've
probably seen her on this channel before
she's been in a couple of videos and
yeah she's she's my favorite there she
is with Manolo she yeah she's she's so
much my favorite that I put too many
pictures of her in this slideshow here
here's her begging for attention and her
and I have a fairly complex
communication system and that
communication system has developed
between us over time as we've lived
together and signals the actual symbols
that the words that exist in a
communication system they might not be
words might be colors they might be
whatever these signals they start out as
cues and this is what biology this is
this is what we we learned in biology
this is what comes from signaling theory
so this this idea of cues and signals
cues and signals are two very different
things to a biologist zoe has has
developed a communication system with me
when she's thirsty when she's out of
water and this started out as a cue what
would happen is when she would ran a
water and her dog bowl she would go into
the bathroom and she would lick water
off the bathtub from whoever last took a
shower and the set up of my house my
office is right next to the bathroom and
so I can hear her little her little
toenails when she's in the bathroom and
when she when she jumps into the bathtub
and starts licking the the water so I
would get up you know I am a cuter I
would detect that cue like oh crap
Zoey's thirsty
and I would get up and I would go fill
her water bowl and she is waiting over
for water as I'm filling it and and so I
was a cue detector and when I detected
that cue I changed my behavior and it
just so happened that my change of
behavior
was something that she liked it
benefited her and so what she did she
she realized that I was detecting a
queue and after realizing that I was
detecting a queue and that she liked how
I responded when I detected this queue
she started doing something else she
started doing something easier when she
was thirsty when she ran out of water
because of my negligence I just forget
to fill up her water bowl in the morning
she would go to the shower and just she
would put her claws on it and she would
make noise and this is what she does now
she'll go and she'll just rub her claws
so bang her claws against the the
bathtub and I will hear that and I'll go
running out and I'll go get her water so
this is a signal this is an active
transmission so she went from a passive
transmission of just going and drinking
water that was just something that she
was doing she was not at all trying to
communicate with me that's a passive cue
she went from from transmitting a
passive cue that she was thirsty to
transmitting an active signal that she
is thirsty and now we have a new word in
our communication system that she's
developed with me and we have all sorts
of things that I mean she and I live in
Canada I live in Montreal and it's funny
because my dogs they actually understand
more French than I do because Marilyn is
she speaks French and she mostly trains
our dogs in French and I train them in
English and so they're they're bilingual
so yeah there's though yeah
Canadian Allison holy crap so he's
adorable and thank you for answering my
question I believe I had the flow of
cause and effect jumbled in my mind yeah
yeah
so yeah Zoey Zoey is amazing but but
this is not exclusive to dogs this is
not exclusive to even humans but you
know this happens between pretty much
all thinking animals so when two
organisms with thinking brains are
motivated to cooperate they can
transform queues into signals and that
helps them cooperate in whatever way
they're going to cooperate in the
and you see this you'll see all sorts of
these signalling systems developed
between animals with thinking brains and
it's beautiful here's a here's kind of
an equation for this so a queue which is
passive becomes a signal which is active
active transmission so passive
transmission then active transmission
and this you know ends up resulting in a
communication system and there might be
just one word one symbol in that
communication system or there might be
many symbols in that communication
system it just it depends on how long
the relationship lasts and how intense
that relationship is how much
cooperation there is so again when two
or more organisms so humans need not
apply signalling can can occur between
different organisms here's a coyote and
a badger that have joined forces to hunt
together and here we see this coyote
he's like come on let's go let's go
let's go hunt he's telling this this
badger that it's time it's time and he's
like okay okay I'm coming and you know
people get mad when you kind of
personify animals like this
anthropomorphize but this really is
communication this this is the the
coyote and the badger they they are
signaling to each other that this is not
this is not an illusion this is real
communication happening and this happens
between all sorts of different species
birds and and and everything I used to
work at a used to volunteer at a
wildlife rehab center and we would train
birds and you can train a bird through a
very simple process of you know you you
give it food and so when it when it
realizes that it's cooperating with you
I need to do this thing for the audience
and then I get this food this treat that
I love most the the bird learns how to
do that and as an animal trainer you
learn how to speed this process up but
it's a it's very very common all
throughout the animal world to to learn
and to develop communication systems you
know between other members of your own
species and between members of other
species happens all the time
so in computers the encoding and
decoding rules of a communication system
they have to be set up in advance or
they don't have to be but they are set
up in advance
there actually are cases of things
evolving over time now that we have AI
different AI systems can end up
developing their own languages between
each other as well but for the most for
the most part the encoding and decoding
systems in a computer are set up and
advanced but in thinking animals the
encoding and decoding rules of a
communication system they can develop
over time they do develop over time it's
just if there is incentive to cooperate
queues become signals and a
communication system emerges this is
completely natural if you have a
thinking mind and you are cooperating
with another organism that has a
thinking mind here's another example
when I was a when I was in Boy Scouts as
a kid we had bears in our region and
there they were actually black bears I
have a grizzly bear here we did I was in
Oregon and we don't have so many grizzly
bears there what we do have we do have
black bears they're very common and
bears do not unless they're starving
they do not want to encounter a human
humans are dangerous humans are
unpredictable bears have just kind of
learned don't mess with those guys
unless you're really hungry and you
really you're really desperate they're
there they're not an easy kill in
general and so bears want to avoid you
and but if you startle a bear by just
walking up on it it will defend itself
and it'll get in a fight with you and it
can it can get injured and you can get
injured and it's no good for anyone and
so we were you know the bear is
listening for queues of people it's
listening for foots footsteps in the
woods and so on we were told that we
should magnify that and walk loudly when
we're in bear
bear territory we should talk with each
other loudly and you can actually buy
bells that you can wear and you can put
on your backpack
for warning bears that you are in their
area and bears respond to this of course
there are some instances where you know
if you've if you're in an area where
people use cowbells
well cow bells are ringing for dinner if
you're a bear like so you don't want to
wear a bear bell in a territory where
people are also using cowbells but
anyway that you you're sending out the
wrong signal right there can be signal
misinterpretation there but in general
these bear bells are there's there's
actually miss mixed studies mixed
results from studies as to whether or
not these work well but we do know that
if you're talking loudly as you're
walking through the woods and making a
lot of noise bears tend to pick up on
that and they get out of way they avoid
you so that is an example of a sig a Q
which is just your sound becoming a
signal when you magnify that sound when
you actively transmit a sound you've
you've gone from aq sender to a signal
sender and you're doing that for the
Bears sake well for your sake and the
Bears sake
so again Q as passive transmission I'm
really hammering this down because it's
hard it's hard to hard to get a Q is a
passive transmission so here
someone has gone to the toilet and then
left the seat up which is a cue that
that a man was there using and peeing
while standing up and then you have a
signal which is active transmission this
dog is really trying to make it known
that he peed right there and that's
that's very different you have a a
passive transmission it's actually
easier to leave the seat up than to put
it back down afterwards so this is a
passive transmission and then you have
active transmission this dog is really
you know putting in some effort here to
aim as high as possible to let others
know that he exists so
again that's that's how they this is an
example of a signal that exists in a
thinking animal but how do signals
evolve here a flower has evolved these
bright colors to attract a pollinator
and the insect understands that signal
and it has come here if for nectar and
it is going to collect pollen and
pollinate other flowers not really
intentionally it's going to do that you
know just because it's going from flower
to flower but that is the consequence of
feeding is pollination so super super
interesting how did this evolve and I've
got a bunch of examples of flowers here
these are some of these are from Oregon
so this one here is from Ecuador I do a
tour of Ecuador every year I used to I
don't know if we're gonna be able to do
those again with COBIT this is from
Oregon these beautiful flowers here
growing in the and the clovers here this
is from my my buddy Jeremiah his
backyard this is an Ecuador up in the on
top of a mountain here beautiful flower
there California Ecuador this is in
their their botanical gardens and the
created these are all different
different signals that have evolved to
attract different specific species of
insect and in some cases birds to
pollinate and you know these are all
flowering plants there are angiosperms
and the flower of the plant is of course
its sex organ and it's attracting plants
because it wants them to help it have
sex with other plants and the the
insects are an intermediate they bring
the pollen from one plant to another and
I'm sure that's all elementary review
for this audience but I have this this
meme that you may have seen on Twitter
as a token of my affection please accept
this bouquet of severed angiosperm
genitals I find it very funny that this
is what we do when we're in love we give
each other sex organs severed sex organs
of another species to show our to show
our affection to one another it's super
strange ritual that we do that's how we
signal to each other which is disturbing
but anyway so so flowers they they exist
and it's a mystery how the heck did this
evolve if we look at non flowering
plants this is a gem a gem no sperm
gymnosperms they don't they don't
develop these complex flowers with these
beautiful signals that are transmitted
through the air instead for the most
part gymnosperms they just spit out
pollen into the wind and that wind will
sort of you know sometimes bring that
pollen to another plant and pollinate
that plant and this is very ineffective
right you have to make a lot of pollen
and that pollen could go anywhere it's
it's it's really rare for it to actually
hit its target even when a lot of pollen
is produced and so you know the the the
the flowering plants they're doing a
similar thing but way more specific that
bug that insect that butterfly that that
bee it goes to one flower on one plant
and then it immediately flies directly
to another plant covered in pollen it
climbs around on that plant and a
pollinate set plan so this is way more
efficient right the efficiency
difference here is insane and what a
beautiful advantage that that is and we
think that this evolved from something
like a gymnosperm
it originated in a plant sort of like
this and the big clue for this is that
some gymnosperms
actually do have insects that can help
in the pollination process so here we
have beetles
these these beetles they they detect the
cues the cone shape from quite a long
distance and they go there and they
actually live inside these cones they
eat pollen so they are pollen predators
and if you have a pollen predator
any mutation that makes pollen stick to
that predator on part of its body that
it can't easily clean off any any
mutation that will allow that to happen
is going to aid in pollination because
yeah you're being attacked by a predator
and it's devastating to you your pollen
that's so hard to produce is being eaten
but it's also sticking to the predator
and when that predator goes to another
another cone that is going to be
transmitted but you know there's a
chance that that pollen will be
transmitted and fertilization will take
place so any mutation that causes your
pollen to stick better to that predator
is going to help you pollinate another
plant so that is going to benefit you
and there's going to be a point in your
evolution as this happens if the if this
interaction continues long enough there
will be a point where the predator is
actually more of a help than a danger to
you because of the fact that it
pollinates other cones so here we have
once pollen predators become more
helpful than damaging any mutation that
magnifies the cue that you exist that
you have a cone that helps the predator
find a cone will be beneficial so
anything that magnifies aq will be
beneficial and what does a magnifique a
magnified you a magnify q is a signal
and we have found that in these these I
always forget how to pronounce their
names
I've had people explain this to me many
times I think it's psychic the psychic
plant we have found that psychic plants
they emit this really nasty odor during
their mating season and it's funny
because the psychic plants are beautiful
people have them in their homes people
have them in landscaping but when when
it becomes mating season for this plant
they start to emit this really nasty
odor that people hate you got to put
your plant outside you gotta you avoid
walking in that area of your yard
because it just stinks so bad and they
are actively transmitting signals to
beetles
and this this relationship between say
kids and beetles has existed for over a
hundred million years we don't know if
they're actively transmitting signals
this early but we have found that
beetles they have been fossilized with
pollen that resembles sacred pollen on
them
see I pronounce it like five different
ways now sigh kid I'm just gonna stick
with that psychic plants so these
beetles have the the pollen on them in
fossils that are over almost almost a
hundred million years old so it's the
relationship has been happening for a
long time we don't know how long the
active signaling has been taking place
but today there is very active signaling
by this plant it really transmits an
odor and it does other things it'll
actually drive them away with certain
odors and it'll attract them with
certain odors so so once they've been
collecting pollen for a while it ramps
up that that that odor and it actually
increases the temperature of the of the
cone and it drives the beetles out and
then they go find another cone and so
it's actually a very complex signaling
system that exists today between these
specific beetles and this specific group
of plants so it's a really complex
system it's evolved here and and it's
different than the then the signaling
system that evolved in flowering plants
so we see that this benefit it's it's
it's when there's a benefit to the plant
that a signaling system will develop and
it develops gradually it appears to
develop gradually cues become signals so
cue any passive transmission a sender
makes that can be detected by another
organism signal any transmission
actively magnified by a sender because
its reception by a receiver helps the
sender better survive and reproduce so
over evolutionary time this happens in a
very similar way just the same way that
it happens between thinking organisms
that are cooperating when there is
selection pressure evolutionary
selection pressure to cooperate
NOLs evolve from cues this happens as
long as their relationship is existing
long enough signals will evolve
naturally so they again they can develop
between thinking organisms or they can
evolve between two evolving entities
under selection pressure to cooperate
here we have warning colors and again I
could do a whole lesson on this but
these start because predators are they
just didn't like what they just ate or
what they just killed and they're
looking they're looking for something
about that organism that was that that
they can remember to look for in the
future so if they ate a frog that had a
little bit of red on it and like
normally I love the frogs that I eat but
this one made me sick what was different
about it it had a little bit of red of a
red tint to it well then they're gonna
start looking for red and then that
makes it that that produces an
evolutionary pressure if enough of these
predators are looking for red to avoid
red that produces an evolutionary
pressure for the Frog to become more red
and eventually there's going to be a
point where camouflage is less important
than being red and and then that that
red can become a symbol of toxicity and
as we see here with these butterflies
these butterflies are also extremely
toxic and they are signaling that they
are toxic with the blue and the orange
and that is evolved different
independently and it's a different color
so that it's not that the color is it's
important it's that it can be recognized
by a predator that's what's important
and these relationships these signals
evolve very slowly but once once they
become strong other organisms can figure
out what they mean just by interacting
with these animals
so it's it evolves slowly it can it can
evolve from anything again there's you
know humans are good at picking up on
colors we can't pick up soil and smells
but animals are in plants are emitting
all sorts of sense that you know sittin
there signaling with with smells as well
they're sailing with all sorts of things
anything can become a symbol in a
communication system here we have a
mimic this is a non venomous snake
mimicking a venomous snake by pretending
to have venom glands it's actually it
puffs up the size of its head and birds
of prey
think that that is a venomous snake and
so they're they're reluctant to eat it
they don't want to get bit and that
works really well can signals backfire
like attracting locusts instead of
pollinators ask Gaurav Sharma yes they
can this happens quite a bit when when a
predator from a different environment
comes to a new environment a lot of
these signals are misinterpreted and
they can go and you know hunt the thing
it's usually bad for both of them right
because the predator will get poisoned
and sometimes die and the prey item will
die also because it got eaten so yeah
it's definitely backfires backfires a
lot also if a species if a male is
trying to communicate with a female of
his own species by making some sort of a
bird call whatever a predator can pick
up on that and hunt the animal so it's
really fun go out into a pond at night
when frogs are calling and you'll hear
them get quiet around you because
they're trying to signal to their mates
like hey look at me I'm ready to mate
but they don't want to accidentally
signal to a predator Hey look at me I'm
ready to eat and so they they're very
cautious as they're signaling and these
butterflies that I showed you in the
opening slide the blue butterflies they
can actually hide their coloration
they're bright blue on one side of the
of the wing and like a brownish black on
the other side so they fold up their
wings and hide that when predators are
around and then they open it up and
flash it when they're trying to
communicate with their their partners so
you have the evolution of symbols and
and oftentimes the ability to hide
that that's that symbol because because
it can backfire so yeah that happens a
lot that's a good question
this is really interesting this is our
Red Deer and this comes right from the
textbook from Stuart's textbook he does
have color photos in there as well but
this is a this is a couple of photos
from an old paper that was these are
photos taken him you know black and
white kind of less high quality than I
usually to put in my slides but these
deer they will howl at each other or
growl in mating season what happens is
the males fight for dominance and then
the females mate with the most dominant
male and so this top guy he's howling
he's growling there's different things
that people call it but he's signaling
how big he is and this is this is what
we call a what it's a specific type of
signal called a a gosh I'm forgetting
the name of it it's an index there we go
it's an index of his size so mm-hmm
sorry my voice is really struggling this
morning he growls and the the the depth
of the the sound made by that growl is a
direct correlation of how big he is and
so he's warning to other males hey don't
mess with me I'm huge and that makes
them stay away the second part of a
fight the the male when growls are
matched the males will come up to each
other and they'll size each other up
visually and if they can't figure out
who's bigger after doing that then
they'll fight so the fight is the last
resort and this is the same thing
happens with humans by the way we size
each other up like crazy before we
actually get into a fight just go to a
bar and watch this happen in real time
well I guess I can't really watch this
happened so much now that we're all on
lockdown from kovat but as soon as bars
open up in your area and and there's not
risk of a disease go and try and watch a
bar fight it's it's it's amusing to
watch people size each other up but
actually an actual
fight hardly ever happens it usually
just people size each other up and then
they they realize who's who's stronger
and they back down but this this happens
in animals as well and they have this
complex signalling system and humans
have a complex signalling system as well
and it's not it's not one that we're
very much aware of we size each other up
without really knowing consciously
what's happening it's we haven't evolved
signalling system between fighting males
that exists even in humans it's really
interesting but the funniest thing about
these these these red deer is we know by
looking at their Anatomy this is an
honest signal of sighs these growls are
but we know from their evolutionary
history by looking at their Anatomy that
there was a point in their history where
they were lying to each other because
the voice box has moved back to the
chest it's expanded and fills up the
entire neck and goes down into the chest
and what was happening is it was easier
to lie about how big you were evolution
was was was pulling the voice box box to
change in size to lie about how big they
were and they could actually Bluff and
get away with it sometimes and avoid a
fight by lying and that that there was
there was an evolutionary arms race for
lining about how big you are and so they
have this really exaggerated voice box
and it's it's to the point to where it
can't be exaggerated anymore the actual
neck would have to grow to exaggerate
this now and if you grow your neck out
longer that makes sure your antlers it
makes your neck weaker during a fight so
there's a there's an evolutionary
pressure to keep your neck you know at a
certain size and so now this signal is
is honest again they cannot fake their
size through a growl but it's really
funny that you can see that in their
evolutionary past they were liars they
were lying for a time there and this is
most exaggerated in the gosh this is a
hammerhead bat their voice box goes all
through their body it's like halfway
through their chest all the way down to
the diaphragm so they have maxed this
there they also signal their size
through a type of growl in their voice
box and yeah so they're they're the most
extreme liars in the the animal kingdom
when it comes to trying to to tell each
other how big you are Canadian Alison's
he said or we call it hold me back
fighting in my region yeah yeah hold me
back fighting is it's very common in in
a bar of course there are there are
reasons beside aside from being scared
of the size of your opponent in humans
it's also illegal to fight in most most
areas and we this is true in most
animals and animals do not want to fight
they will avoid it at all costs and so
they do they do these these signaling
contests before a fight even predator
and prey
you know things will make themselves
look bigger than they are they do all
sorts of things to try and Bluff how big
they are and that happens in in nature
is and and it happens in humans here's a
really cool example of dishonest
signaling this flower is sending out
pheromones so their scent they send out
all sorts of chemical signals right that
they're transmitting all sorts of
signals and somehow during the
evolutionary history of this flower of
this plant one of its molecules that was
sending out happened to be similar to
the sex hormone of a a bee and that made
males come to this flower thinking it
was a female and they would check it out
and sometimes try and mate with it and
that helped in pollination you know
having this bee climb all over you it
doesn't matter if it's collecting nectar
or what it's doing doesn't matter as
long as it's climbing all over you
you're benefiting because it's gonna get
pollen stuck to it it's going to go to
another flower and pollinate that one
and so this thing is actually
specialized it no longer produces nectar
nectar is a bribe to get insects to to
pollinate them and no longer produces
nectar it just specializes in one
hormone
one sex hormone and this fur here is
tactile it kind of feels the way the
hair is on a female be feel and so all
of this causes the B to stay longer and
copulate with this flower here's a be
actually copulating with the flower and
it's got pollen stuck to it that that
yellow thing on its butt there that's a
pollen packet specially adapted to this
one species of bee that this flower is
it's lying it's saying I'm a female bee
come meet with me and apparently this is
not really hurting the bee because this
relationship has been maintained for a
long time
maybe it's actually even good practice
for the bee they found that bees that
have actually copulated with a real
female they're less likely to get
tricked by this but new bees will get
tricked into this until they meet a real
female and then then they tend to figure
it out but this is hilarious plants are
lying to insects and it's it's good for
them they no longer have to spend so
much energy producing nectar anyway I've
got a little bit of time here again for
questions before I jump into the final
segment here so I think I think it
should be clear at this point that that
cues can become symbols signals in a
communication system and it doesn't
matter if this happens through evolution
or through animals figuring this out
with their brains
it can happen either way plants can do
it I haven't really talked about it here
but bacterial signal to each other
through chemicals your tissues in your
body signal to each other and you know
this is this is they do this through
hormones and we're going to learn that
that chains of RNA in in DNA they send
out signals to ribosomes in your body so
communication happens all the way down
in biology biology is layers of
communication so I'm going to get a
couple of questions here when was the
first signaling system
asked by a keysight channel that we are
going to talk about
Minoo when the very first singling
evolved because it's probably long gone
by now but the the oldest signalling
system that exists is the genetic system
which is chains of RNA sending signals
to the ribosome and those signals it's
it's telling the ribosome how to build
specific proteins so there is the oldest
existing signaling system that we see in
biology is the genetic code that that is
a communication system that exists
between maliki volva ng molecules so
chains of RNA can actually evolve in the
laboratory we we know that chains of RNA
can evolve on their own and they can
adapt to their environment they need a
little mini an enzyme that can help them
replicate so this is not something the
model of RNA evolving independently
doesn't yet work in a prebiotic
environment so we're trying to figure
out how RNA or something similar to RNA
would have evolved without enzymes and
things that you know these modern
biomolecules that exist today that is
the big question in evolutionary in
origin of life chemistry is how do we
get an evolving system without enzymes
but RNA is a molecule that can evolve
without it evolves on its own if you
give it an enzyme to let it reproduce
and the genetic code appears to be a
communication system that evolved
between different chains of RNA because
the ribosome which is what builds
proteins it's actually made of RNA its
core that does the protein building that
is an RNA core and the messenger RNA
which tells the ribosome how to build
proteins that is a piece of RNA as well
and so this is an evolved
communication system between two
evolving entities under selection
pressure to cooperate and this
communication system is maintained by
these two evolving entities the ribosome
and the the well the nucleus of the cell
and eukaryotes but really
just messenger rna's this communication
system is maintained through
evolutionary pressures to cooperate to
build protein and we think that it
actually evolved under selection
pressure to build protein so that is the
oldest version and actually the rest of
my slides actually talk about that in
more detail Tim Smith
I think cephalopods are the best say at
signaling what do you think well
cephalopods were I guess humans we can
cephalopods can signal through flashes
of color in their skin and cephalopods
dolphins they can communicate
cephalopods might be communicating a lot
more information per second than humans
can because of their the way that they
signal they flash these complex you know
groups of light and dark on their skin
to signal to each other they might be
signaling a lot more information than we
are per second and dolphins might be
doing the same dolphins there's reason
to believe that dolphins can project a
three-dimensional image from one
individual to another with a chirp
because they see with radar they have
this visual their visual systems is
highly activated through their auditory
system they can actually see images with
radar and because they can see with
sound they can probably think that they
can mimic sounds that give each other
three-dimensional images and we think
this because of a series of experiments
they were done where they'd show an
animal or one dolphin a
three-dimensional image and that dolphin
had to communicate that image to another
dolphin to get a treat and we think from
those experiments that they are able to
do this through sounds they can
communicate three-dimensional images to
each other which is super cool but yeah
there's there's a lot of signaling
happening in nature all kinds see did I
miss a question here
whare of sharma asks are there examples
of communication systems having to adapt
because human interference like ship
noise disrupting whale sounds maybe yes
yes actually many many many signalling
systems have adapted had to change
because of human interaction the one
that I know of that the actual study
that I can tell you of is on frogs in
Oregon and I actually helped on this
research I filmed a bunch of it and I
need to put it together and make a video
I've I've been meaning to do this for
years it was like six years ago that I
filmed this and it's like yeah but we we
went out and we I only helped a couple
of nights but we would collect we would
listen to frogs signaling in ponds that
are really far away from freeways and
ponds that are right next to freeways we
measured the differences in sounds and
they were quite dramatic they've they've
changed the frequency of their call to
adapt to car noises that they're Rumble
in the range of their call and so they
actually sound differently and this is
just individual real-time adaptation we
think we don't think there's evolution
happening there we don't think the voice
box has changed but I suppose if if this
were to happen long enough you'd
actually see an anatomical difference in
populations near freeways versus far
away from freeways that could probably
happen but it's yeah what we do see this
all the time
organisms adapt their signaling
strategies because of human interference
that's that's a good question I don't
know I have a black screen on it here
here's my face hi that's better than
black screen right hopefully let's see
here
dolphins also have names or signatures
whistles for each other yeah I've heard
that as well squid tsamina Kate
communicate with a secret skin power
alphabet not yet but I will now thank
you okay yeah so there is we have
decoded we don't know we don't
understand so far as I know maybe we do
but I don't think we understand the
communication systems that exist between
cephalopods I think that they are still
mysterious to us we just know that the
communication is happening it takes us a
lot of time to figure out how different
organisms are communicating with each
other it's very complicated we we just
recently learned that butterfly fish are
actually telling each other hey a member
of your species don't come here because
I'm eating the thing that you want to
eat and it's I'll have to fight you that
like figuring out that signalling system
that exists between butterfly fish that
was super recent and yeah pretty much
anything that you look at it's weird
that makes no sense like why is this
animal colored this way it's because
it's signaling to another member of its
species or it's because it's signaling
to a predator I mean you don't want to
over apply a theory but in general
that's what's happened every time we've
looked into the one of these or really
weird traits it turns out to be a
signaling system it's communication so
it's and that's that is super super
common that that ends up being the case
do you know of any other uses of symbols
other than the human writing system well
yeah everything I've been talking about
here these are symbols so the the color
of a flower is a symbol that is not that
has nothing to do with whether or not
it's it's got pollen right the color of
a flower is a symbol that is being
transmitted to an insect in the case of
the the growl of a red deer that's an
index you wouldn't call it a symbol you
call it an index because it's a it's
just showing how big the animal is and
it's it's an honest index that the
flower color is a legitimate symbol it
has nothing to do with there's no direct
correlation between you know in physics
there's no direct correlation between
the color of a petal and how much pollen
there is that is an evolved symbol that
the flower has developed and the insect
has developed it's it's it's a symbol
it's evolved between these two entities
it's very it's an abstract symbol and
and this is what we see the the the the
hormones that are transmitted from ones
when part of your body tissue to another
part again there's nothing there's
nothing about testosterone for example
that makes cells grow in a masculine
manner it's it's because there is a
receptor that's evolved to to receive
testosterone and then that through a
series of chemical reactions that have
evolved in a Cell enzymes that have
evolved causes the cell to change its
behavior when it when it receives
testosterone this is not there's nothing
in physics that dictate dictates this
this this communication system has
evolved between tissues in your body
let's see as evolution given us such
intelligence that we can understand
genetics and manipulate it won't it be
good to modify ourselves as we desire I
I guess you're asking did did this
evolve so that did our intelligence
evolve so we can eventually manipulate
genetics no there's no evolution does
not have foresight so things the fact
that we just figured out genetics is
really circumstantial it's not
understood why we evolved to be so smart
but it's also often misunderstood how
smart we actually are as individuals we
are not that intelligent there are
certain tests that chimps beat us on
like routinely their memory memory games
that chimps will always beat humans on
it what the secret to our success is our
cooperation in groups and the ability
now through writing to conserve
information we can pass down things that
we've figured out from person to person
and and parent to child through teaching
and from person to person by talking to
each other but other
can talk to each other as well other
animals can show each other things you
know you see monkeys that will teach
teach each other how to open shells and
so on and that will that will be passed
on from generation to generation
you see monkey cultures develop monkey
technologies develop but we have this
writing system we have this really
intricate abstract communication system
that we have developed through speaking
and this allows us to really ramp up
what we can accumulate the technologies
we can accumulate it happens that
through that we have developed the
ability to edit genes and this is
nothing that evolution foresaw evolution
doesn't foresee anything and it's not a
thinking thing it's just the process
it's just descent with modification
acted upon by selection and it happens
to have produced a species because it
was beneficial they can cooperate with
other members of its species and that
cooperation became so exaggerated then
we can now manipulate our own genes it's
crazy to think about how this unfolded
but yeah it's it is it's really an
accident of circumstances that we can do
this now just selection pressure was
favoring communication and cooperation
and now we can modify genes in a lab and
that might not be good for us actually I
would argue that it it's probably the
most dangerous thing we've learned how
to do because we can now manipulate and
we can make bacteria we can make we can
make weapons now that were unthinkable
in the past and we can make them for
cheap so I wouldn't I wouldn't say that
genetic engineering is a good thing for
our species it might end up being a
catastrophe so not to worry everyone but
that that really could be the end of our
civilization actually let's see so
nonliving things can have a
communication system non well computers
yeah but communication systems like this
active communication systems they do not
emerge between
nonliving things the the active that a
signal remember in in biology is an
active transmission of what used to be a
cue right and that transition you need
so far as we know you need evolution to
cause that to happen so evolving
entities now some people don't want to
think that biomolecules are alive but
biological biomolecules are evolving
entities and so they can develop
communication systems between each other
bacteria can develop communication
systems between each other and so on
through the process of evolution but if
you don't have something that's evolving
if you don't have to evolving entities
descent with modification acted upon by
natural selection then so far as we know
there's not another way for a
communication system to develop where
you actually have active transmission
and encoding and decoding that actually
happens actively evolution is one way
that that can happen and a thinking mind
inventing a system it's the other way
that it can happen and we don't know of
an alternative let's see if we can teach
chimps sign language can't they teach
others yes that actually happens a
little bit
but the sign language chimps don't seem
to be able to use language in the same
way with the same same complexity that
humans do there's something very special
about the human mind and the way that we
use language the chimps don't get they
don't they don't get far past you know
adding two or three words together to
make a sentence when they use sign
language and they're actually using
grunts and other gestures that are so
subtle that it's hard for us to
understand they were using them before
they learned sign language before people
started teaching them signs they were
already doing this with each other we
just didn't understand it so it's like
it's funny because like dogs are better
at learning human signals than humans
aren't learning dog signals right and
the same seems to be true with gyms like
they
they pick up on our language better than
we pick up on theirs but they they will
teach each other signs and they will
develop signs on their own one of the
chimps at the I think it's the Portland
Zoo it might be the Knoxville Zoo I
worked at both of them and I can't
remember where it was that we had a
chimp that developed her own sign for
humans and it was this she would do this
with her hand and it was we humans have
this bubblehead that's what we think she
was doing she's signing it now they had
though the big ugly forehead and I was
there being trained I was a volunteer
there I was there being trained we were
there after hours and we went to the
chimp area and the chimp was signing to
her trainer so another human with she
was signing to a trainer and the trainer
told us that you know she was doing this
and she was pointing at us and doing
this and she was she seemed really angry
and the trainer told us later that she
was angry because humans were there
after hours it was supposed to be her
time off we shouldn't have to get looked
at by people she did she did not like
people but she kind of understood that
during the day she has to let people
look at her but when the zoo was closed
she it's just her and her trainer and
the other chimps and so she was upset
that people were looking at her so I
thought that was that was interesting on
many levels like first of all a
chimpanzee understands that she's got a
shift she has to work a shift and yeah
it's just amazing like this this that
this chimp developed this this
communication with her trainer
she has her own symbol that she
developed and she's mad that were there
after hours it was hilarious okay
does our gut microbiomes signal our
brains to eat certain foods I have heard
that that is happening I don't know the
details but if so that's going to be
chemical signaling to the tissue of the
stomach which is somehow interpreted by
the brain to feed that microbiome so
yeah I have heard that that that happens
and I've heard that certain microbes can
manipulate that but I do not know D I
have heard the papers at another
research
can communication systems overlap
meaning the same communication system
used by different species absolutely
well the genetic code is the universal
communication system all of us use
almost the same genetic code but let's
see can I think of any other examples
well a lot of flowers can communicate
with multiple species at once you know
because different pollinators have
learned with their brains what that
color means and what that fragrance
means and then multiple species have
evolved to be attracted to the same
colors and the same fragrances so so the
the flower will will be interpreted by
multiple species so one signal will be
understood by many and yeah that happens
quite often all mammals use pretty much
the same hormones so you can take you
can take a testosterone from one animal
and put it into another I think you can
do that and without getting an immune
response there might be issues if the
animals are too distantly related
worried where that can be a problem but
I believe we actually get our
testosterone you get from the doctors
produced by I think it's like a ungulate
I can't remember I don't remember what
what animal produces our testosterone it
actually might be a genetically modified
bacteria to actually produce human
testosterone but I I don't recall but
yeah you the the communication systems
are if they share a common ancestor
they're gonna still be using the same
the same symbols in their communication
system so that that does happen oh thank
you Allison okay can some honestly this
talk has been an antidepressant this
morning pandemics are hard and so
education is that much more valuable
during this time thank you
well I'm happy to help can some
organisms convey messages as complex as
near as neuron can without having neural
network
a neuron is a single neurone Asst is
actually transmitting pretty simple
signals it's an on or off it's a yes or
no signal so yeah it took to the next
neuron
it's consciousness is it's it's still a
mystery but we think that consciousness
emerges from lots of neurons talking to
each other we think I mean who knows if
that's actually the case there's been an
argument that consciousness or the
ability to experience reality that that
ability is emerges from the brain and
other people claim that the brain is
somehow tapping into something some
other system that exists in nature like
some force it's not currently understood
and with current science there's
actually no way to tell which one of
those is true both either one of those
could be true most people assume that
it's an emergent from the brain but the
only thing that a neuron is really doing
it might be doing other things that that
allow consciousness to emerge that's
different than what we see it doing but
what we see neurons doing is they
transmit chemicals from one nerve to
another and those chemicals cause an
electrical signal to get passed down the
next neuron down the line which then
when that signal reaches the tip of that
neuron it transmits a chemical signal to
the next neuron so it's really just a
yes/no it's an on-off signal just like
in a computer the zeros and zeros and
ones is very much how the nervous system
works and yeah other organisms convey
that as well inside of a cell you have
really complex computations that are
happening in my guest on here it's gonna
be in two weeks he's gonna be talking
about that he's going to be talking
about the cell from an engineering
perspective all the things that are
happening inside of a cell and to think
about these in terms of communication to
think about these chemical reactions in
terms of communication and signaling is
a really neat way to think about it
because it really is what's happening
that the the spectacular thing about
life is that we have communication
systems inside a community
systems inside of communication systems
and it's these interactions that make
life so unique you don't have to think
of life that way you can think of it
from just normal chemistry but we really
do have these evolved systems where you
do have symbols testosterone is not
causing the cell to change its behavior
it's it's interacting with it with a
sensor on the outside of the cell a
molecule on the outside of the cell and
a chain reaction with a bunch of
molecules that have evolved to cause
this chain reaction under selection
pressure to to cause this chain reaction
that's what's causing this there's
nothing in physics that says
testosterone needs to change a cell's
reaction it this is evolved this is a
system that has evolved and that is
really spectacular I think I've if I
have missed questions please resend now
there's one more from plants shouldn't
have consciousness if a brain is needed
for it yeah I would agree but plants do
have complex signaling so in brain
really is just a signaling system so far
as we can tell it's ace it's an
information processing system and a cell
is also an information processing system
you can think of it that way it is
processing information from the outside
and changing its response in accordance
to that information and a plant's body
is doing that too and the weird question
about consciousness is you know I I
experience consciousness am I thinking
the thinking part of my brain
experiences consciousness it's possible
that these sub what I call the
subconscious part of my brain is
actually experiencing something just as
lively but I don't this part of my brain
that I'm using to experience my life the
storytelling part of my brain doesn't
have access to its consciousness it
might be a closed there might be closed
systems of consciousness even within the
human brain and there might be there
might be something similar to
consciousness
you know physicists are arguing this
philosophers are debating this
biochemists are debating this is their
consciousness in a Cell or something you
could call consciousness in a Cell what
do we mean by that word like this is
this is a mystery in science so I I
wouldn't jump to conclusions to say that
a plant does not have consciousness I
would say that so far as we know a plant
certainly doesn't have consciousness the
way that you and I do they're not
thinking about stuff and then responding
and they're not worrying about things
but we don't know if a plant experiences
its it its existence we don't know we
have we just don't know and we don't
know if a cell experiences its existence
so that things start to get a little
wound will here when we talk about
consciousness because it's so
misunderstood it's so so it it is a
mystery and a mystery so let me get back
to my slides here I've got a couple more
I'm running along on today's lesson but
this is really interesting stuff to me
this is my one of my favorite things to
talk about and I've never done a proper
I want to put together a proper like
edited lesson on all this stuff a it
needs to happen I just haven't done it
yet but so signaling as I've been saying
is fundamental to life absolutely
fundamental it's some people say they
it's it's really the thing that
distinguishes living from nonliving and
so these are two cells that are actually
I forgot what this slide is I think
these are immune cells attacking some
pathogen yeah those are definitely
immune cells I don't know what they're
doing there but they're yeah that they
use signals to communicate to each other
like we've got a bad guy in here we need
to kill it and they they pick up on cues
from the pathogen that oh there's a
pathogen in here this thing does not
belong so there are there's Q detection
and signaling happening here between
white blood cells
and a lot of this a lot of this I've
already talked about in this QA so you
know hormones are tissue to tissue
signals transmitted through the blood
this is a a signaling system that is
evolved between cells bacteria signals
to coordinate many behaviors they can
signal to each other they can signal
between members of the same species they
can pick up on cues from members of
other species and they will change their
behavior accordingly and in some cases
there is reason to suspect that they
probably have interspecies communication
so they actually have evolved signals
between each other but most likely you
know signals it's easier for signaling
to evolve to evolve between members of
the same species than between different
species but we do think there's probably
some cross species signaling because
they live in quite complex groups and
ecosystems the genetic code is a
signaling system and and with with
symbols that have evolved so this this
is the genetic code cart chart this
tells you what the the nucleotides they
come together to create codons and those
codons are signals that represent
different amino acids that are to be
used by the ribosome to create a protein
and I apologize if everything I said to
you is gibberish there I do have a video
series called what is DNA and how does
it work that will help clarify that your
functional bits are mostly protein and
the thing that the genetic code is doing
it's it's a signaling system between
chains of RNA that where they
communicate with each other how to build
different proteins so yeah they're
chains of amino acids and the amino
acids are just these molecules right so
here's aspartic acid this is what the
actual molecule looks like in
space-filling form and this is a
nucleotide these are the nucleotides of
DNA I'm just rushing through these
slides here because we're kind of
any overtime here but this is what a
nucleotide looks like in space-filling
form so we have that amino acid that's
what the amino acid looks like that's
what the nucleotide looks like and in
the genetic code three nucleotides on a
chain of DNA or RNA is actually what's
sent to the ribosome to actually act in
the communication three of them make a
codon and they are a symbol telling the
ribosome to grab a glycine from its
environment and add it to the growing
protein chain so they the the the
symbols encoded in the chain of RNA are
understood you could say understood in
quotes because there's no brain there
but they had the the ribosome has
evolved the the it's actually using
transfer RNA to to interpret the
messenger RNA and it knows that the
system knows the roles are set up in
advance that a guanine guanine guanine
in the messenger and I'm really
stumbling here I apologize a guanine
guanine guanine in the messenger RNA
represents a glycine and so it grabs a
glycine out of its surrounding adds it
to the protein chain and then it reads
the next three nucleotides in the
messenger RNA and it grabs whatever
amino acid is symbolized in the
communication system for it to grab so
this is a genuine communication system
that exists at the heart of biology and
it's the oldest the most ancient
communication system that exists and it
is universal almost universal in all
organisms this this codon chart here
this chart is slightly different in
different species the symbols are
slightly different in different species
but for the most part it is the same I
want to say different species that means
certain certain bacteria use a slightly
different version than animals do but
all animals use the same version
so I actually have a talk on what is the
genetic code that's on this channel
where I go for these slides in more
detail and without so much stuttering so
I suggest going over that but in short
the flow of coded genetic information
goes from DNA in in modern in the modern
system goes from DNA to messenger RNA it
is it is modified and encoded into
messenger RNA that is transmitted into
the that is transmitted to the ribosome
and that tells the ribosome how to build
specific proteins and so we have a a
signaling system that is just like what
we learn about in information theory so
you've got an information source in this
case the ultimate source of the
information in the genetic code is
evolution but it's that the the stored
source is DNA that is encoded by a
transmitter but the the nucleus encodes
that into messenger RNA and transmits
that out to the ribosome the ribosome
receives that in decodes that
information into protein and this is a
very the encoding and decoding system
the rules that govern the encoding and
decoding they evolved over evolutionary
time to be what they are today and we
think that they evolved probably in some
sort of an RNA and world scenario where
the first evolving entities were chains
of RNA and they were under evolutionary
pressure to cooperate to build proteins
and increasingly specific proteins as
time went on and so different symbols
developed in that communication system
between different chains of RNA the
ribosome is a chain of RNA and it's it's
it is a chunk of RNA that folds up into
a three-dimensional shape and acts as an
enzyme it can actually take those amino
acids and combine them into a protein
chain and that
system we believe evolved and this is
quite a bit of a bit more speculation
than we would like right now this has
not not been demonstrated to it to a
degree that's really satisfying but our
best speculation right now is that that
communication system evolved among RNA
chains that were replicating going at
undergoing Darwinian evolution so
descent with modification acted upon by
natural selection and they evolved this
communication system they that became
more and more complex as time went on
until you have this really sophisticated
genetic system that ended up taking off
and all organisms now use this same
system essentially the same system so
yeah that's that is today's lesson
everything from the genetic code to the
colours of a flower to the the words
that I'm uh Turing right now these are
symbols in communication systems that in
most cases in many cases have evolved
and in some cases have been invented or
not necessarily invented English was not
invented right it emerged between humans
who are trying to cooperate with each
other so languages these these
communication systems the rules that
govern communication systems that can
evolve through evolution through natural
selection or they can be generated by
thinking organisms that are trying to
cooperate with each other and in all
cases this is the result of cooperation
and evolves when different evolving
entities are under selection pressure to
cooperate and it emerges when different
thinking entities are under pressure to
cooperate so there we go
signaling Theory combined with
information theory and this will really
help set us up for our conversation on
looking at the cell from an engineering
perspective here in two weeks and again
next week we will have a conversation
about the origin of life from a
Christian who studies origin of life
chemistry he's an actual researcher I've
been working with
for since 2012 doing animations on the
origin of life and he's a really cool
guy j-47 Forsyth and I I'm very excited
for this week's this week's lineup but
that is it for now well actually let me
just see if we got any questions here
any last minute questions plants respond
to a dark place and know to go vertical
that is through yet they do have sensors
plants do have sensors that can detect
light and they can they've got a system
that causes them to grow towards light
human signals to other humans via cough
runny nose and red eyes that they are
sick our viruses bacteria evolving to
make us more asymptomatic so we are not
signaling in those cases we are sending
out cues and other humans can detect
those cues so remember the difference
between signal and of Q is that a Q is a
passive transmission a signal as an
active transmission and that can be a
little bit you know there's kind of a
blurred line there but if I were
exaggerating my sneezes to get attention
then I would be sending out a signal
yeah if I was actively exaggerating the
sound of my sneeze if I was just
sneezing I'm just sending out a Q so are
viruses bacteria evolving to make us
more asymptomatic the sneeze is how is
the best way to be transmitted so the a
coffin a sneeze actually throws a virus
out into the atmosphere and that's how
its transmitted you could if a
population becomes super terrified of
sneezes and coughing and coughs which we
now are you could have selection
pressure for them to evolve more through
or sorry transmit more through surface
surfaces and so on and so they might
actually yeah you could have
evolutionary pressure that would cause
them to
hide themselves better but I don't know
of any studies on actual observations of
that but yeah and in theory that that
could happen let's see for feeding my
information addiction thank you
oh yeah you're welcome Tim Smith and if
you have a last minute question do at
stated to space casually and I'll make
sure to that I see that I'm getting some
thank yous oh people are talking about
people been talking about training
positive reinforcement and clicker
training the click the reason that bird
trainers I say bird trainers cuz I used
to Train birds with a clicker the reason
that animal trainers use the clickers
because it's a it is a signal that you
can tell the animal hey you just did
what I wanted you to I'm going to give
you a reward and the clicker is a signal
that never changes so if you're giving
if you're giving out verbal signals to
an animal your voice might be different
every day you might say it slightly
different every day it's it's hard for
that animal to really grasp everything
especially animals that are not that are
not very sound oriented humans are sound
oriented and visually oriented other
animals it might not be so the clicker
is so distinct that's why people use a
clicker when they're training it's a
little clicking device that makes a very
distinct clicking noise that it pretty
much any animal can figure out that
weird noise means I did something good
and so I'm going to get rewarded so that
that's why it's a shortcut to developing
a communication system between a human
and another animal a key side channel
says I sent you an email on how DNA came
came about I have not seen that yet but
I will look for that
can any other questions here
well it looks like that's it I'm gonna
wrap up I've been going for almost two
hours
so yeah so long for now everybody thank
you this was wonderful and I will see
you next week with my guest J Forsythe